et avec nous dans cette suite Philippe
benasaya bonsoir vous êtes le
porte-parole du Conseil départemental
des Yvelines nous allons parler
notamment de la cinquième édition du
comptoir de Noël qui va se dérouler au
domaine de Madame Élisabeth à Versailles
mais avant cela nous allons parler
politique avec vous ce sera ce weekend
se déroule le premier tour du congrès du
parti les républicains les militants
sont appelés à voter pour le futur
président du parti en ligne ou dans les
points d'accueil physique ils auront le
choix entre Bruno Retailleau Aurélien
Pradier ou Éric Ciotti est-ce que vous
avez fait un choix est-ce que vous avez
vous allez soutenir un candidat alors
d'abord la transition un peu compliquée
parce qu'on a quand même parlé de choses
très sensibles comme vos combats que
vous menez et le téléthon nous sommes
tous élus locaux mobilisés sur sur le
Téléthon dans mon canton de Bois-d'Arcy
Fontenay-le-Fleury Saint-Cyr vous l'avez
rappelé on est on sera très mobilisé
donc transition plus sensible mais on va
quand même parler un peu politique et
c'est important c'est très important
parce que c'est une grande famille
politique les républicains issus d'une
belle tradition Gauliste donc c'est pas
une une élection anonyme vous allez dire
que je vais faire une une réponse de
langue de bois mais c'est pas du tout
mon habitude c'est que d'abord je suis
vice-président des républicains 70 donc
j'ai un devoir de réserve par rapport au
prochain futur président qui va être élu
donc il faudra travailler avec lui mais
je pense que sur le fond je vais vous
répondre sur le fond le sujet et le
suivant
quel que soit le président qui sera élu
que ce soit irisotti ou Bruno Retailleau
ou Aurélien Pradier le travail est
immense qui nous attend il est pas
forcément politique parce qu'en fait
quand on voit à la carte des Yvelines
voir ailleurs
l'implantation des républicains est
plutôt plutôt satisfaisante nous avons
des villes nous avons des agglomérations
nous dirigeons des régions nous
dirigeons un département dont notamment
celui de des Yvelines donc
l'implantation loc on est plutôt est
plutôt forte il y a deux problèmes qui
nous handicapent depuis des années le
premier problème c'est le problème
culturel qui sommes-nous que
devenons-nous et ou allons-nous et
qu'est-ce qu'être de droite aujourd'hui
et qu'est-ce qu'être républicain
aujourd'hui parce que ce soit ce type
rotaïeu ou Pradier il faudra répondre à
cette question il vous reste peu
d'espace j'ai envie de dire entre le
parti de Macron plutôt libéral et le
parti tôt souverainisme de Marine Le Pen
c'est ça parce qu'en fait je vous
rappelle que les républicains sont issus
d'une déjà d'une alliance qui était
l'alliance de l'UDF et du RPR qui est
devenu l'UMP avec toutes ses composantes
libérales radicales conservatrice
souverainiste une partie a été captée
par des parties plus souverainistes une
partie a été captée par par le Centre on
va dire macroniste et donc on ne sait
plus qui qui
tu fais quoi et comment on est perçu et
ça c'est la vraie question alors
franchement très honnêtement je vous
réponds c'est pas la langue de bois ce
soit sur retail ou pradique ils devront
faire ce travail de de visibilité et
puis et de culture qui sommes-nous et la
deuxième question et c'est là où on est
le handicap c'est que nous n'avons pas
de leadership c'est pour ça que nous
sommes très fort localement mais que
nationalement nous perdons pourquoi nous
perdons d'abord à ce que nous n'avons
pas fait de travailler culturel et ce
travail de d'identité mais en plus
surtout parce que nous n'avons pas un
leader qui à chaque fois rassemble nous
l'avions en 2017 avec François Fillon
mais ce que vous avez vu leur parquet
national financier qui a été d'une
extrême rapidité d'exécution dans une
campagne électorale bizarrement et puis
depuis il y a une sorte de descente aux
enfers on n'arrive pas à retrouver un
leader qui puisse s'incarner ce courant
de droitier très probablement
majoritaire dans le pays
vous souhaite retrouver dans les
Yvelines par un des trois candidats
pourquoi pas oui peut-être quelqu'un
d'autre Éric Ciotti vous avez entendu
que s'il était président DLR
soutiendrait Laurent Wauquiez ça peut
être quelqu'un d'autre nous sommes loin
comme des présidentielles je sais que
les journalistes sont très très
focalisés sur les présidentielles même 5
ans avant c'est la question qu'on nous
pose tout de suite qui sera le futur
président de la République moi j'avoue
que j'avais pas vu arriver Emmanuel
Macron un an avant donc je me je me
pronostiquerai pas là-dessus mais c'est
surtout le travail qu'il faut faire
avant retrouver un grand parti retrouver
une identité retrouver une culture
politique que nous avons perdue et après
trouver un leader qui incarne ce tout ce
courant politique de droite qui est
honnêtement majoritaire dans le pays